so when i think back about when i came
to nfl
what year what was your rookie year it
was 19 1973
1973 i now look at an nfl now that's
based on
meritocracy college doesn't matter that
means no matter what color you are how
fat how big you are if you can
bring merit to that team you'll get
yourself a good contract
that speaks volumes if people understand
how far we've come then all of a sudden
saying we're a racist place doesn't work
anymore i mean i know what racism looked
like i know what systemic racism looks
like
we have an opportunity right now to do
anything we want to
[Music]
before we do the policy stuff i just
want to do a little
bit more on your history because as i
said earlier you're one of the three
first black people uh football players
at university of miami and then let's
talk a little bit
about nfl and just sort of how the how
the sports mindset
and and going for a championship and
winning and all that stuff
how how that set you up as a human being
okay
good question let me let me just first
of all kind of uh put in context
the environment of the nfl when i when i
when i when i joined as opposed to today
because i think the biggest part of us
being excited about our future
is knowing about our past and there's
something that karl marx said that said
it all
the first battleground is rewriting of
history if they steal our past
we truly do not have an appreciation for
we are and we have no vision for where
we're going
so so that being context again i grew up
in the deep south days of segregation
uh 12 years old i remember uh marching i
was the youngest person at that time
i was with the florida indian when my
dad was a college professor
in front of state florida state theater
because we couldn't go into to
to look at a movie state of there um my
dad just a little extra background my
dad actually came back from a very proud
uh
proud uh world war two that could not go
to
get his postgraduate down in texas
because of the jim crow laws
and i remember running across a box of
letters when he passed away
of all these rejection letters that had
gotten across the country
that would not accept him to those
colleges and i looked through it
and i realized it was a racist thing but
he never ever brought it out
he never talked about it for him it was
it was motivation
and that's what those folks did there
was motivation he ended up going to ohio
state where he's got his ph date
he ended up being a 40-year uh a
professor there and it was an
entrepreneurial research and we traveled
around the world i was five years old
living in liberia africa uh that's the
again that's the environment this is the
50s
i had an older an older uncle uh but by
the way
he and his older brother both got their
phds at ohio state
dad got in agronomy uncle lima got it in
in economics he ended up teaching in the
university of houston
the oldest brother was probably the
smartest one he was an engineer
and uh he loved planes but he couldn't
do that when he went to service
so he on a part-time base he ended up
buying a little this is 1962.
nobody bought planes in 1962
particularly black folks
but uh he bought a little plane and
because he was entrepreneurial he was an
engineer but he lived in wichita falls
texas
he took letters from wichita falls base
the military base to chicago that was
the sad time business
the first uh fedex and i remember him
coming
flying to tallahassee and i must've been
maybe 12 years old when i had my first
flight in an airplane
and uh my i remember that experience
very well because he took us up they
took me up
and i don't know if you know what the
air uh with the stall i'm sure you know
what stahl means what it's all about
but if you don't know what a stall means
it's good to know before you stall
before you
get the experience it feels like falling
out of the air
and i remember stalling getting panicked
he kind of got control
smiled at me and taught me what airplane
lift was i know today exactly what
airplane lift means
so but i'm i'm making that fun either
way
no no i'm making that point because i
want people to know
that my community was truly one of the
most competitive communities in our
country
one that was so proud of we we educated
ourselves because we knew that's what we
needed to do to to compete
my my degree was in biology my minor was
chemistry
why did i was able comfortable to do
that because my dad was a college
professor he had a laboratory i feel
very comfortable
and the most important thing is when i
was told by someone in high school that
i could not do that
i made it my my duty i lived in the
library university might be to prove
that guy wrong
because that's the attitude we had in
those days so so that was the
environment
again i went to university of miami i
was i was drafted to the jets
when i got to the jets um this is this
is the way it was in those days
uh there was no black quarterbacks
centers free safeties
or middle linebackers in those days the
message of
the democratic party was the black
people couldn't think we were not
leaders
we could run we could jump we can play
music but
thinking was not out it was out of our
wheelhouse
by the way to that point when you go
back and see martin's the king
you see the marching i want you now to
keep this in context when you see them
notice he has white white shirts black
ties sometimes business caps are always
business shoes
because they were going against the
narrative of the leftist of the
the racist of of of
illiterate uh lazy bumpkins
can't talk uh all the negatives you
could possibly think of
and they were showing in the way they
marched and they're disciplined and
non-violent
that they were totally off base and they
wanted to make sure
their kids understood that not to take
the narrative of these people
to be proud of who you are so i just
want to put that in there so so when i
think back about when i came to nfl
what year what was your rookie year 1973
1973 i now look at an nfl now that's
based on
meritocracy college doesn't matter that
means no matter what color you are how
fast
how big your if you can bring merit to
that team you'll get yourself a good
contract
that speaks volumes if people understand
how far we've come then all of a sudden
saying we're a racist place doesn't work
anymore i mean i know what racism looked
like i know what systemic racism looks
like
we have an opportunity right now to do
anything we want to i can not only go
into a theater i can own a series of
them if i wanted to
but it comes down to recognizing that
the differential in every single race
every single person in terms of success
is based on those four tenets very
simple to understand i think it's time
that we
find a way to explain conservatism and
explain
the american way the entree to the
middle class
simply we spent too much time trying to
debate it it comes into four tenets
head heart hands at home education
faith industry and family it's that
simple
if we educate ourselves we no longer
could be
be manipulated by the leftist who wants
to keep us dumb and motivated by emotion
if we understand that faith is the
answer to everything this is the country
was built on
the deal christian values period and no
matter how we worship him
the reason why we look at each other
inside our verses outside in better than
any other country
is we believe there's a god in heaven
that makes us want to bless
we want the blessings by blessing others
industry
we now understand as a country that we
are not that country that wants a 10
10 month vacation that's just not us we
want to work
we want to sweat we want to we want to
man fall flat and get back up because we
feel good about the process
that's who we are and that's why we've
always let out the entire world in terms
of producing things because we that's
that's in the dna of our american people
the last but at least is our family
the family unit detects how where our
country goes and how
how high we how how we fly and that's
why that's why the left has been after
us for a long time destroying the family
unit
we should always think about very simply
the way i was brought up
is the best thing i could do is is i
want to i want to make sure that my
family's name is one that's respected
it's a legacy for my dad
my mom if i do if if i do the kind of
things what they're proud of that i
that i carry their name and i do the
same thing to my kids
that we have we have done a great deed
for our country
and for my for my family and for my race
and for my as a citizen
that all works out so the family is
really the key point and uh and we just
have to get back to understand what that
reason what those what the roles might
be and all that kind of stuff
that's a long answer to a short question
but i hope i got there buddy
i think you got there i think you got
there so you you mentioned the
meritocracy of the nfl now and i think
that goes
obviously for all professional sports at
this point nobody cares
what color you are it's can you play i
mean and for me
i'm a basketball guy but when i when i
play ball my entire life any court that
i showed up to
nobody cared if you were white or black
or asian or anything else what do you
care about
can the guy put the ball in the hole
that's that's the only thing that you
care
about yeah
just win baby that's it there's a
certain beauty and a simplicity to that
uh but when you see things you know how
politicized sports has become
so you may remember about a year ago
there was a big thing in the nba that
they didn't want
the players didn't want the owners to
call them owners because that somehow
had some connotations to slavery or
something but the simple fact is they
they own the team i mean they own the
team that that's how it works that
uh when you hear these things and and
you hear it from people that are
multi-multi-millionaires that make money
that you could never do
do you remember how much you made your
rookie year oh
i'm almost ashamed now keep in mind
first round draft choice
get ready first round draft show is the
third 13th pick the first defensive back
my bonus was 50 000 a year from the 50
000
and i made 20 23 25 and 27
the first three years and those last
three those those years were not
guaranteed by the way
i had to go out and make that happen but
uh no it's right now guys
now guys like an eight-year guaranteed
hundred million
is crazy if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell